okay thanks mom so many coming back
alright so yeah let me remind you of the
sitting there we are so we have a fixed
number of variables a fixed degree
everything's fixed so finite dimensional
vector space today we are working in its
this vector space here everything is
finite and so and do you have a
complexity and we can take so usually
you want to have this one this is a bit
more instructive right use a bit simpler
questions but this one is it works in
the server I didn't know so in this very
general it works for so the argument
works for different complexities is no
problem so you can take this one on the
P the P thing now is and is that set
here so we want to we want to have we
want understand this set because we want
to show for some fixed permanent that it
doesn't lie in in here right so it fix
the duty so we want to show permanent
doesn't lie in here so the theorem is
that if you look at these polynomials
with complexity is at most n chose it
this is an algebraic variety
and this is very powerful
all right thank you but it's also uses
yeah uses some theorem some algebraic
geometry that I I think are very
important to be understood in in quite
some detail to advance the theory right
so what we basically yeah we basically
just call these theorems as black boxes
right so this is a problem this is what
I mean it tells us that there is this
nice structure and but then we need more
information we want to know what are
those separating polynomials so we have
to understand this much much better so
so um okay let me sketch this may be
that certainly is don't say poop
residence pool sketch and now um so this
so we want to have this additional
structure on the set okay so first of
all we prove that is so-called
constructible so what's the
constructivist set you have a set of
constructible so first of all algebraic
varieties are constructible and now
and this expects the word is that you
have finite unions or finite
intersections or complements are also
part of constructivist sets also
constructible so you can take arbitrary
boolean combinations so these are
constructible that's the definition not
and so you define what's a polynomial
map so here's a map goes from some
complex vector space say tsongkhapa to
say your dimension
heydo algebraic varieties themselves and
now thanks
so what is it is yeah oh yeah so they
are not closed algebraic varieties are
not closed under compliments so you get
the risk you open sets here and also
yeah but they are you can take finite
unions and finite intersections but once
you take off limits and now you take
compliments and take and now it gets so
you basically have a variety you cut out
a different variety you remove it and
let me actually maybe give you an
example so if you take this is actually
a nice one so you take a zero set of y
squared
plus 2x squared plus X so on they are so
this one has the following if you plot
it it looks a bit like this
zero said is this you sit here ah should
be symmetric somehow yeah well I mean my
dry skills are significant limited okay
and that's a point here
that's this point so this is the zero
set of this variety okay I understand
it's funny all right
so this is the and now you can remove
for so this is this is the variety and
you can get a construct with set for
example if you remove the point right
but then it's not an algebraic variety
anymore of it what is the point that
point is a minus one zero here I think
it's minus one zero
yeah I guess so yes you can plot yeah I
mean this is the real picture right so
this is for the real numbers this is the
picture view picture over two variables
here x and y so there's as an x-axis and
there's a y-axis here it's because the
power of Y is is positive at some points
I mean this is just the set of this
polynomial yeah I say my Y is
discontinuous this is where it's
positive yes where the where the left
hand side is past or right hand side is
positive is you have a point yeah yeah
if you look at this and then here you
get this yeah you touch basically you do
you have a zero here right from the
right hand side yes the complex numbers
I mean yeah over the company summers I
wouldn't look like this I mean that
would be yeah over the convex number is
the picture is different yes obviously
okay so but if you okay so this is if
you remove the point and this is this is
Euclidean closed still over the reals
but is not Euclidean closed over complex
numbers right
so the approximate that point
arbitrarily close to over the complex
numbers I mean if you look at as you
were set here if you remove a point from
a variety over the Copic service always
and if it's a reducible okay
anyway that's just a picture of an
algebraic variety and and how you get a
construct was set it's just you remove
for example a point still the concert
will set okay it's just a construct we
set all right and okay and so I want to
now write the set here as an image of a
polynomial map because I really have
this property that it will be
constructible so ordered what is this so
I want to have some map here and it
should be a should be a so-called
polynomial app so let's call it a don't
get mapped
each of these ADA target functions is a
polynomial in the Kappa many variables
here
and now we will find that our set C will
have the structure we have to be will be
the image of a polynomial map so each of
the ADA target quartet functions
here's a polynomial
in kappa input coordinates so for
example and this is yeah so this is very
instructive so I think so example of
this is how do we get 1 and 140 new
mates in this very tiny example here so
maybe that's - let's make this our
running example here yeah so we get a
saying given alpha and beta and it will
output a coefficient vector that looks
like I have a squared well for beta beta
squared now this is the coefficient
vector for roaring at one polynomial
right
there's expert explained Y squared so
therefore the image is here so the image
of this map here of this polynomial map
is now indeed exactly this the set of
warring rank 1 polynomials and you can
so you can do this in a very general way
so in general and it's not difficult to
do this it's just you know you can
always say that sources mean our set up
let this set where the complexity is at
most P is the most accuracy of piece at
most n is always the image of a
polynomial map and so what is that map
it's the map where you put in the
coefficients all the linear forms that
you so for example if you have an an a B
P then then on the left hand side you
have all the coefficients of all the
linear forms that you put on all edges
and now you map it to and this gives you
the coefficient vector of the egg of the
polynomial well that's a polynomial map
that's a bit of config it's a very
complicated putting on my map but but it
is easy to describe it so you get this
four warring rank a BP complexity
everything right and now so the theorem
is now that we invoke Chevrolet's
theorem and it says that if you have a
point of a map then the image of yeah so
why is the point of map so which protein
am happy do you take so you take a
coordinate map that that has on the left
hand side so what you input is all the
coefficients of all the homogeneous
linear forms on all your edges of your
ABP and that's a that's your and you map
it to so you map it to a put into the
whatever the ABP outputs but to each to
the coefficients that i output it right
so the coefficients of the polynomial
that you output so that's that's your
map okay so what you're using is that
the class has a universal circuit yes
yes yes yes yes that's the universal
circuit exactly defines it follow me on
that yes that's true so you always do
that actually so we always we always do
that so for warring rank it's a
universal circuit for a BP is the
universal circuit and so the the
classical set up was determinantal
complexity where you have a universal
circuit and you always do that yeah you
want to get rid of the of having several
different circuits that you have to work
with it's take one of the universal one
yeah take one universal one and that one
yeah
and whatever it computes us now in the
image of this polynomial map the
branching program I think of like a
fixed yes everything's fixed yes indeed
so you need to fix your structure of
your branching program may be assumed
the or layer so same size so then fixed
number variable to fix a degree you fix
your n knows
okay that's also to that fixed end all
right this is important also fix em and
now see what is the structure of this
set and then now everything's fixed and
you just get all the polynomials that
you can construct in a finite
dimensional vector space it's a subset
and it's the image of a poly know that
polynomial map and so the theorem is is
called Chevrolet's theorem it says that
the image of a constructor will set
under a polynomial map is constructible
again so but you start out with just
your you start with the whole C to the
kaepa so that's obviously constructor
but that's just the whole space and now
you map it to this where I know my map
and you get something that's constructed
and they're so construct one has as a
nice property now so image of a
crosswalk was it
all right so we conclude the set is
constant so yeah the setters construct
and and no I mean I'm without to say
without the closure but so maybe we do
we do without the closure at this point
but if the complexity this is
constructed we know that's already very
nice because there's additional
structure let's find more structure of
the set um all right so there's a
theorem that tells you that if you have
a constructivist set then the Euclidian
closure is equal to the Whiskey closure
of that set and that finishes the proof
but you see I mean that this very is not
very explicit right but but this is what
it does so if you have some subset so
what is the risky closure oh there's a
risky closure of a set it's just you
take your smallest I you take the
smallest algebraic variety that still
contains your set okay so it's a closure
zu risky is the smallest
that bright variety containing X and
this is the same is look at all
polynomials yes 0 X and we'll take the
vanishing acceptor or zero for those
polynomials yes is the same that is
exactly that that's exactly that you
look at all the polynomials vanish on
the set and take the common vanishing
set yes okay so this is the risky
closure and so this is another in so
this is in particular is an algebraic
variety right now the theorem is that
I works over the complex numbers that if
you have a constructivist set and the
closure is equal to the risky closure
the usual Euclidean is the same as those
risky closure
the usual closure here Euclidean is
equal to the risky culture this
presumably relies in complex numbers
because over there yes this is why I've
chose this example yes missus why I
chose this example because here this
doesn't hold over the reals I saw
there's a subtlety going on here if you
remove this is the Euclidean closed but
but this says that it yeah
the closure should actually coincide so
what yeah so if you have these two
theorems then it tells you now that this
is an algebraic variety so one st
understand is much much better to
actually find out what are the equations
I mean to even get hints about what
these sequences should look like that
you want to have to cut this out right
this is this would be important I think
okay so it's two different one I mean
I think it's so
well I mean reasonably difficult so but
it yeah it it takes some it takes a
significant amount of pages and I like
to have actually a nice and concise
proof that is independent of any yellow
books I mean you can it's not that you
have to go to page 250 or something
that's not that bad
all right it's not that bad sorry it's
reasonable okay let's try to set this
much better at all okay so but if okay
let's just take this now and I mean this
is this is amazingly nice now but we
have we have even more so we have even
more structure on this set so this is a
this is one thing is an algebraic
variety but now we also have a group
action on this variety right so you can
actually supply more structure so yes so
you're saying that closure gives you an
algebraic variety okay
this one was not right and this one was
not now this one is not a black variety
this none you can you can prove that in
most cases this is not so they're very
rare that this is an algebraic variety
so for example you have 1 1 then this is
an algebraic variety but even yeah so an
algebraic variety is close yes only be
an algebraic variety if this closure is
it so yes yes I mean so there's two
closures now all right pesky holders
yeah but if it's if it's a variety than
all the closures yes that's also true
yeah and the closures are the same as so
you got a clue yes that's true and this
one yeah so we've seen examples where
this is not right so what I'm going to
bar over I'm going to was then close but
yeah we're going to was not at all
yeah so this is yet but this is that is
an issue yes so this is also where
something happens at the boundary where
things come in that we don't really know
how to control yet right
that's yet all right I think there are
results that make part of this effective
yes but I don't have the exact pass for
anything so one would have to look it up
I do think that there are versions of
these things that are more extreme or
explicit than what I've wrote but yeah
it's just yeah we'll take some work to
to go through it
let me show you one more thing though
okay so I want to show you one more
thing because that is all very nice but
polynomial sister one can do better a
bit better so we want to find more
structure now on this on the set here so
we want to study status set of points
and now there is let me do an
instructive first example so say you
have a wine rank 3 polynomial so you
start say with a say you're putting
ominous X plus y JQ + so when I do
waring rank because I think it's easiest
to understand what's happening in
warning rank and because you can easily
lift all these ideas to do break
watching programs is very simple but
it's very hard to draw the algebra
project programs
that's the only reason here so now you
replace now X by say X plus y and this
is what is this is a group action here
and so what you get is I mean so you the
result is then this you get a X plus 2y
I saw was very easy and
but what you observe is that the number
of cubes didn't change obviously right
saw them under this operation the
complexity is preserved right I can
actually it could go down under this but
it can now it cannot go up right so if
you do things like this and so this
means that so that's a short rotation
for this so this is what people in
representation to you use they use a
short notation which is that put a
matrix and they put the linear forms
where you in the columns will let say X
is X is replaced by X plus y and Y is
preserved by just why replace / just Y
of P and a and this is this this is a
way of writing this so columns are yeah
let me actually put this maybe so
variables are replaced for homogeneous
linear forms given by the columns that's
the usual way of doing this because if
you do this has a nice property I'll
tell you in a second so the variables
are replaced by homogeneous linear forms
given by the columns we can just think
of it as the composition of P with the
matrix yeah literally years
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that is true you
can yeah you can think of it like this
this is very true all right so you saw
the observe then and this is now obvious
if you if you have your viewpoint this
is now obvious that if you have a G 1
and G 2 and you apply them then it's the
same as G 1 G 2 and apply it to be right
there's no obvious so and this is what
you want so this is the action of an
action right so now you have an action
of your of your Monroy dove matrices now
they can move your points around and and
so the walking rank also doesn't so
actually your complexity you can do this
now for for for war in rank or we're
going to write branching formal
complexity doesn't really matter so it
cannot cannot go up if you do that yes
invertible matrices is the same yes
indeed so for invertible matrices
obviously from this argument it's the
same so therefore this means that this
set he has a structure right so that you
can now apply matrices that i invertible
that's exactly what Jovi Marcus alright
so this means that you can apply
matrices sometimes people write it like
this arrow here so you can apply
matrices here that are invertible say we
have M variables and this is GLM now you
can apply these Center have some
additional structure on your set yeah
this is very nice what you call so we
call this a this is not quite a GLM
variety because it has it's a variety it
has a GL m action on it and so if you
have that then you can do much you know
much more about how to separate points
from your variety because
of a conceptual thing that happens now
on your functions so if you want to
separate your your variety from a point
you do this with a function that
vanishes on your variety and it doesn't
vanish on your point so if you study now
these functions yeah if you study these
functions then this action lifts to the
functions in a canonical way right and
that is but that is a conceptually very
interesting way but is completely
canonical so you can maybe let me define
because now this is where we were
working in so defined I want to work in
some space of polynomials of degree
Delta and and the coefficient should be
putting limits of TBD so the variable
should be polynomial of degree D in M
variables let me let me just write it
like this and maybe say this is the
polynomial ring but the variables are
the polynomial is so this is a finite
dimensional space inside this is this
kind of thing that we are working in
right so the example would be here the
discriminant that was Delta and D and M
where all - right so let me do and one
example here
well maybe maybe a bit is more
instructive is if you put the dimension
then you know precisely what this what
this space is right so the defamation is
this binomial coefficient but it's all
nested right so there's a D plus n minus
1 choose D plus Delta minus 1 and the
nurse to state I know this is a large
dimension and so for example you have
that if you do everything is to let's
have a look at our very simple
discriminant example where the b squared
minus 4ac this
it's being screen that's not this should
be a delta oh I try to make it that
attack yet and that's the Delta and
that's the degree okay a subscript is
the homogeneous degree Delta part so
yeah let me let me give this example
here okay so this has a basis and the
basis is given by a a squared a B AC P
squared PC and C squared so here in poly
C squared pulley to C squared every
polynomial so every this has a basis you
can maybe yeah so you maybe you can
write ABC here and now you're to take
polynomials here to homogeneous DB to
polynomials here on the set alright so
in particular you have here in here you
have the discriminant right so there's B
squared minus 4ac this function here is
living in here and you can check for
example if you can evaluate it here at
these points to check if it's a yeah so
there's the two levels of polynomials I
thought this is a bit problem yeah so
it's nested so that's a conceptual issue
I like that everything is polynomial ABC
because those course my yeah so this is
also already this is the first thing so
this corresponds to x squared XY and
this corresponds to Y squared and that's
all the two variables in gb2 and they
have coefficients ABC and now you go to
degree two on that one and you get this
one here and that's one element of the
space X plus y here yes yes exactly it's
now if you know place say if you replace
yeah the simplest one is if you if you
if you just do you replace you just
switch X and y let's just say that Y the
switches x and y so in in here it was
switch a and C alright so she do this on
the coefficient vector a be
and you get CBA all right but now this
also works of course if you have
polynomials and there was variables and
so this is a bit of simplified version
of this but but this this is how it
should look at this so in particular if
you look at the b squared minus 4ac well
that's you replace the a by C and B is
fixed right so this is still b squared
minus 4ac and if you're now yeah if
you're now into tedious calculations
then you can actually have a look at
what happens if you take any 2 by 2
matrix and you apply it to b squared
minus 4ac and you'll get that this is
the determinant of t squared times P
squared minus 4ac okay so the
discriminant
or on property it is invariant under
determinant one matrices right so the
special in your group preserves this
polynomial and yeah alright it's good so
but this is a bit of tedious calculation
so okay so what is it okay so this is
very good because now we actually do
okay so what we just saw is that
actually we do have an action of grm now
on this on this finite dimensional
vector space over here right that's
that's very nice the representation
theory will help us to find out what
polynomials could possibly be the ones
that separate our point from our variety
that's what we want I mean separating
the point from the right is equivalent
to having that lower bound is the same
same same thing
all right so we want to do that for that
I want to define the type of polynomials
that are now of interest so that's a
very special type of poets that we only
have to look at and those are called
highest weight vectors and yeah what for
for defining this I let me first define
and what is the partition I mean what
what come here talks people called a
partition so you have an M tuplet
so just I'm trying to define our a
special type of polynomial here in that
the discriminant will be one of those
well you bear with me for a minute okay
so and I'm the producer scored a
partition if it's non decreasing lambda
1 greater equal to number two and so now
I want to have a what is called a
highest weight weight or so lambda is a
partition err
then a polynomial I say we call it say
the poor never should be F and it should
be some so something like of the
discriminant 23rd have fully D some
polynomial that is on the space of
polynomials in this very special case I
want to have a look at this is called a
a highest weight vector what weight
lambda following holds so two properties
that define this and one is them one of
them is if you apply G to F then this
should just be F if as long as G is
upper triangular with once on the mind I
are gonna okay so for example the
discriminant has this property because
the determinant of this is just one okay
so that is true
and the second is so you want if you
have a diagonal matrix say you have some
constant C on your diagonal after one up
to F of M and you apply it to your F
then it's just rescales
and how does it risk its risk eighths by
F of 1 to the lambda 1 for 2 to the
lambda 2 so that just tells you how it
we skates and yeah
and so the discriminant also does that
so the discriminant actually rescales
so if you'd give issue yeah if you do
this on the discriminant yeah it's great
for the two - all right so if you do
that alpha 1 alpha 2 C was you on the b
squared minus 4ac then this will give
you alpha 1 squared alpha 2 squared
times P squared minus YC so this is the
highest right vector of weight to - okay
so why did I define this okay so this is
is weight vector because of the
following
yeah because of the following theorem
now so and this is the theorem that says
that whenever we want to find approval
lower bound then we can might as well
just prove a low about using highest
weight vectors only we'll also be able
to separate as much it's much less than
all the polynomials it's just very few
where I am in significantly less than by
orders of magnitude
okay so the theorem says so a we have a
variety and you have a point that's not
in the right okay then you will always
find the highest weight rect or
let's call it f maybe of some weight
lambda and we separate so it will they
will have on your variety it's
constantly zero and on your point you
wanted to on your point to be nonzero
but that's not quite true
you have to you have to move your point
a bit so you have to disturb your like
your parrot opieop point a bit by some g
and g some some matrix so this is non
zero or almost oil that theorem tells
you if there's a lower bond then highest
weight vectors will prove that lower
bound right so one has to understand
ties by highest weight vectors right
there's much less vectors then then
polynomials in total so in particular
here so there's this one highest weight
vector P Square minus 4 AC and there's a
second one which is so I mean up to
scale of course so I mean every multiple
of a scalar multiple is also highest
weight vector so this is highest weight
vector so B Square minus 4 AC is the
highest weight rect or off-white tutu
and there is another highest weight
vector which is just a squared and
that's all the only two in this vector
space
well the vector space is six dimensional
right
[Music]
here the weight is fours you want
although those of two vectors that you
get right let me maybe show how this
works
one-handed butter on your hand here to
deal with this almost all the GLM but
that's only I mean that's not so crucial
because what the only thing that you
need to do for the lower bond is you I
mean you have your point
so I mean you want to prove that
something is that some polynomial
doesn't evaluate to zero and you only
have to pick a some G you don't have to
actually do this for more so G right you
just have to and if there's a lower
bound then you find something that you
have to observe it some G that is true
that is that is true but usually I mean
yeah but you don't have to exhibit some
G's that something vanishes you only
have to exhibit some Z that this is
nonzero and this will be true for most
all of them but I agree I agree no I
agree it's just there so that wasn't so
this was hasn't been the issue so far
typically just G being getting it here
something works yeah that depends on
your setup there usually some a bit more
complicated matrix works though it's a
little bit more complicated yeah
so usually you take some oh yeah you
take tiny bit of different matrix
[Music]
because if you have a lot of zeros in
their matrix then the evaluation is
likely to be zero depending on your way
of constructing the is way back to on so
you put some entries
this is pure characteristic zero so the
the representation theory works over
characteristic Z war in the same way yes
you will always have if your
characteristic is you you have this is
just I mean you will see from the proof
it's a very simple fact from you just
need your group to be reductive and you
are and your unique you are general in
your group to have the irreducible
should have this the signalized weight
vector and you have that over a rational
numbers for example okay let me maybe
let me show you so I think this is a
good thing to just show you this so we
started we started that the eleven is
that true okay maybe let me sketch this
alright so it uses some representation
theory right so what you do is so this
is called a representation now if you
have a group action here on a finite
dimensional vector space quarter
representation and so you use the fact
that this decomposes so into what as
what is called irreducible
representations now what's an
irreducible representation is just so
you can so you can decompose this vector
space here into smaller into direct sum
of smaller vector spaces will take
effect you take a vector space and you
decompose it into some small vector
spaces and there should be all they
should be all closed under the action of
GLM okay this is what you want yes
yes no I don't that they are usually a
linear combination of points that are
that are not so they are not home
they're not high site vectors but they
are linear combinations of applications
of matrices to isolate vectors and you
get any combinations it's not so easy
actually to find out what Strassen for
example proof two bound on tensor rank
in where this works and then we have
some works on this also where we prove
also tend to rank lower points using
these techniques also there's lunchbox
resort on land spec money valdés there
also gives precisely the type of the
highest weight vector for the
determinants of complexity of permanent
yes so you have to decompose I mean so
basically for shifted partials you get
this huge matrix and you take a minor of
that matrix and and that usually had
doesn't have these properties but you
can you can yeah you can get it
decomposes so one of the summons
actually would have the properties of
that matrix are not so sure if they're
if they have a natural interpretation in
terms of that matrix one or I would have
to ever look they would be very
interesting so I think so usually if you
want to I mean okay so this is a if you
have any if you have some lower bonds
method and this tells you that there's
also a side vector then usually is not
clear if it's easy to find
what kind of highs wet right or the
races of the right I mean you have some
lower bonds method why would you how
would you know right and then there are
methods of trying to find this out so
Landsberg for example in the practice to
us these things find out precisely
because it's not just about highest I
mean this is about high-tech us but it's
actually the type of the irreducible
representation that separates right this
is what this lambda here with what is
the separating lambda in here you have
actually more than that so and yeah so
you have the following okay so I'll tell
you so those are irreducible so this
means that I don't there's no sub space
anymore right that is also so there's no
fixed sub space anymore so your group
acts in a way that you cannot decomposed
further but now each one had actually
each one has a type so each one actually
each V I so the VIII reducible just
means that they you cannot decompose
them further into the stirred some here
and each each one has exactly one
highest ragtag door
of some type lambda but do you might
have several ones okay so and now okay
so that is but that bad [ __ ] basically
proves that's basically boost effect
because now so okay so this basically
proves the fact because of what you look
at is you look at the functions that
vanish on your variety say we call this
IX Delta should be inside its the
vanishing idea right so the functions
that vanish
on a variety yeah so this should be the
functions to finish okay so now you also
have here on this one so let me maybe
define this property here after such
that f of X is actually vanishing
so now here you also have the group
actions is actually separate
presentation of this one here so here
you have the same group action
so therefore this one also decomposes in
the same way as also in a different
actor in the same kind of manner but
yeah as a separate presentation so you
have less summons right and then each of
the summons has one hi is right back to
it
and now so you decompose sorry we do
some bits and now each of the yes so
each each vir Vijay here has exactly one
hi so a director and more moreover each
of this Vijay is equal to the span all
this is over okay off of that highest
right vector so for each Vijay you get a
highest respect to F J and so F J is
there is way back up to scale I mean but
square doesn't matter because you can be
scared here okay so this means now that
if you have some function that vanishes
or some function here you decompose it
not just over this decomposition but
even further here where this
decomposition to get a basis here that
is just that is just given by some gif J
so here for example you get a this means
that you get each VJ has a basis given
by some
some GI times energy right in a span of
just applications of you so okay so now
you get that your vanishing polynomial
it's in this space but you have basis
vectors that are all of this forum right
now okay
so now your function doesn't vanish on
the point P so one of those doesn't
vanish on the point P and that's it it
was but this one was taken from here all
right so this is the only thing that you
did here was you decompose this you
decompose the whole vanishing idea into
into functions of this form that all of
the form gif J so therefore you find her
so you find you when you do this you
find that exist I and J such that gif J
if you evaluate at P is nonzero and also
gif J is actually in the vanishing idea
and this proves it because this here
this is the same as FJ right this is the
the way whether we defined this F J
applied to so you put a transpose here
for technical reasons this is just this
is the same so when we define this
action here I didn't say this however we
defined this you basically define the
action on your polynomials via the
action of on your on your proteomes that
your work on the coefficients alright so
this is the same I mean if you have an
action on your polynomial here on your
testing polynomial f on your f
polynomials and that's the same as
basically just applying this for P
instead right that's the same that is
how you define this edge okay and and in
this way I mean so in this way you this
is this proofs effect right you
decompose now the variation of your F at
P into some of these kind of evaluations
one of them must be nonzero because your
original polynomial was not zero and
your point
yes oh oh I see okay so that's a
complete classification of the
irreducible of the general linear group
and and yeah and you can look at the
weights that and wait wait so a weight
is you apply a diagonal matrix to your
vector and you see how the scaling
happens and then for each of reduced
width it's completely known how the what
are each other weights that appear and
they form a there's their fault and
that's a partial order around the
weights and they form the they form a
partially ordered set and there's a one
maximal point which is the which is the
got the highest weight but yeah that
requires the basically the complete
classification of the irreducible in
yeah you can yeah yeah yeah you can no
yeah no you can do this more generally
than just general in your group yes yes
that's much more general yes there's a
weight lettuce in general for any groups
you can do this in a very very high
generality if you what - yes so when you
say it says exactly what is weight
vector are we saying yeah well so one F
and that F has also one lambda and the
but the the lambdas might repeat so let
me define actually what is the
multiplicity there come to be several
lambda section e of the several apps of
the same type lambda and that is a that
is the thing that the original GCT
conjectures were concerned with all
right so you want I mean this might be
complicated to look at the size weight
vectors I mean it's a nice theorem well
then now I know I mean it's true and the
nice thing is you can separate with
those it might be difficult to do that
so what you want to do is you only want
to look at how often here it does that's
my lambda type lamda appear actually
each of these V J's has now a lambda or
attached to it and so this decomposition
is not unique but it turns out that the
number of times that each lambda appears
that's actually well defined so you can
you can
decompose in several ways what the types
are often they appear that will actually
be the same as all I mean that's all
known to be very big but right area but
it's not so very hard also in the
lecture notes also so you can look it up
and so but let me define so because this
one maybe be enlightening so if you
define the multiplicity in any any
representation so you have some
representation say V with a squiggle
thing and you define as the dimension of
the space of highest weight vectors of
type lambda in there right so this is
irreducible this one is weight vector
but it could be some decomposition like
this right and then you would you would
actually get several eyes like pictures
of the same type lambda and they span a
vector space that's been actually a
linear subspace right and that's the
code the multiplicity and the
multiplicity is also the same as the
number of times that that your VJ
actually has type lambda in this
decomposition okay so that gives you
what is called the multiplicity so let
me give you examples of multiplicity for
example the multiplicity of 2 to in poly
square P Square C square there's one
because there's a that's the
discriminant right and then we've seen
the other one for 0 is also 1 so you get
these natural numbers now you just get a
bunch of natural numbers but if you get
any other say 3 1 then this is you oh i
don't so one can calculate these numbers
and yeah and now try to use that so
that's actually an open problem so open
problem is it's a big open problem this
is a Stanley's problem number 9 so
Stanley so this which is Stanley
level nine from to the formalist that he
compiled in 2000 he wants to know and
this this number you can you can you act
what what is the count that is what he
wants to know so in other words so the
map if you have a map that's you give
you're given some lambda some Delta some
D and some M and you map it to this
multiplicity here is this map and sharp
P that's the question
it's not how he phrases it but that's
the question so this map is this in
short P so what does it count
and we know gap we know that it's in get
P but that's not enough for
combinatorics people right and now you
can use actually this these
multiplicities now for lower points
that's the last thing I'm gonna say so
you can use size wave vectors so people
then so what I mean what about just
looking at how many high strike totals
of a certain type of there so and that
is you want to prefer that a point
doesn't lie in your variety while your
point as you know right the if and only
if it's all orbit closure is a sobriety
right that's true because yeah that's
the smallest set that's closed under the
group operation and also as a risky
closed and say you Accord this why okay
and now this is not a question so your
lower bound question here is now a
question about inclusion of two
varieties into each other well and they
both have some structure like this and
they're vanishing idea right so both the
vanishing areas so in particular so if Y
is a subset of X then all hi is right
back to us M in so then all the highest
wave vectors in vanish on X they are
also they vanish on y iy is a subset
so this means so it why isn't it you
want to disprove this fact right he
wanted this for what it is prove so what
you get is that the multiplicity in the
vanishing idea of why that is actually
greater equal to the much PST vanishing
idea of X right so this is what you
would get and now
so and you call this and so if this is
violated and you call this a
multiplicity obstruction multiplicity
obstruction so usually this is fries
tuna
usually usually you do this do early so
you in the dual way you do this over the
coordinate rings so instead of the
vanishing ideal you look at the
coordinate ring so you say I define this
as the quotient so I say this is just
booty and so it's just a difference of
ocean now at the vanishing idea this is
where usually what I do break generators
to so therefore you might as well just
also do that and now as a representation
as representations you get that this is
just a sum so you get your pulley data
body the sorry this is the D
I am is a sum so what is the code in
ring and one is the vanishing idea as a
representation and yeah so therefore now
you can also just look at the
multiplicities here all right because
you know I'm here you know maybe here
and then you know them here because they
add up right it just adds up so so
therefore a multiplicity obstruction is
usually written in this way I was
usually written in this way it's it is
sort of multiplicity of in the coding
for X if that one is less than the mark
listy in the corner ring for y all right
so if this is true then we have a lower
bound so why does not line X and so if
this is even zero here then this is
quite an occurrence obstruction
of what ii get covered lambda so the
observe that has the degree in which it
occurs and lambda is so lambda is the
type of the obstruction so lambda would
be the obstruction you would call them
no the obstructions today i I mean there
is some data but so the obstruction are
the data is caught and up so this is
wrong
so there's lambda lambda has caught the
obstruction so actually the holdup I
mean you can take the whole topless
being the obstruction either usually you
take lambda because lambda actually
tells you basically all the other data
will be encoded in them de anyway I
didn't actually say that but lambda
would actually tell you the obstruction
right so there's some multiplicity that
happens to be here say maybe middle 0
and doesn't happen to be here and now
yeah so the question is now yeah
obviously several questions arise now so
do these things exist I mean it's a
sharp enough right all right so that's
basically the question because you are
restricting now to just counting how
many of these types are there and it's
not clear how sharp this is and so if
you um if you have a different model of
computation where you don't use the
homogeneous model of computation so if
you have an F I model of computation
then you cannot use occurrence
obstructions for the lower born so that
is what we proved that is based on some
work by karush and nuns back where they
study precisely what happens in these
fine models of computations and what
happens to the representations and we on
based on that we can prove that there
are no good or curse obstructions okay
but on the homogeneous models we do not
know this right so it was the model is
much much more keen and we cannot we
cannot find a way of disproving that
these things exist ok and multiplicities
so if you want to just compare the much
mestizos open there's no no go reside on
this and so it's possible to do to prove
some things with these obstructions so
as I mentioned so you can prove a lower
bound on the border rank of matrix
multiplication using or coarse
obstructions for example
but very strong but a nontrivial who
were born on the border rank of matrix
multiplication all the lower boards that
are that you can all the separations
that you can do I usually occurs
obstructions so but so we recently found
an example where you can prove that the
multiplicities are actually strictly
stronger for separating and the across
is just the occurrences so we do study
something we cook up some example where
this is possible to show em that tells
some more powerful alright and yeah and
this is unclear exactly how powerful
this is so what did what it does though
isn't some in some yeah in some way and
then be very vague now so we study what
is that
how powerful is it - um so what kind of
proof so how powerful is this type of
proof if you write on these these
inequalities and in some very tiny toy
setting one can say that this that
there's a that this encodes a very hard
function right so it might be very very
difficult for a four point it might be
very difficult to actually get this
multiplicity down right so to study it -
they actually get your but olicity might
be very hard and it might be that hard
so it might even be that harder the
breaks
an algebraic version of a natural poof's
barrier all right so that's it might be
that hard so but in a very tiny toy
setting we are just first studying this
and yeah so this is also so we're trying
to understand better what's the
separation of power of these of these
multiplicities and and does it this is
reasonable to conjecture that it
surpasses any natural proof barrier if
there is any algebraic I mean there are
papers on algebraic versions on this
right it's not so clear how yeah it's
not so clear how big I mean so there's
no algebraic cryptography that's
basically the issue so it's not so
believable so clear how believability
yeah are the is they are bright natural
poof's bear in that that sense so we are
just about that's very very sincere
this algebraic natural proofs for the
stock here there's a barrier Marcus yes
there's a turbine a shampoos do not
clear that there's a barrier so one yeah
okay anyway so why can encode pretty
complicated so we encoded the permanent
in these things and yeah so I but it's
still active area of study you try to
understand so what is the difference
between our current system but this at
least maybe sometimes occurrences are
good enough maybe it just was just at
this but this non-homogeneous version
was just a problem maybe virus at this
moment is a bit unclear right
so the highest wave occurs always work
[Applause]
[Music]
sequence offense yes yeah yeah you get a
lambda for everyone I mean to get a
different lambda for everyone plus form
understanding of the entire sequence of
obstructions yes yes yes s you have an
infinite sequence of obstructions in
that case yes you need to have an
infinite sequence of obstructions and
you have yeah you have to have some
understanding of how these lambdas
evolve or H n grows yes yes that is true
so this happens for example for the if
you look at the lower bound for the
transit rank of matrix multiplication
you get a sequence of lambdas and for
each one you get a different lambda it's
getting larger another
building on that question there's a way
to index representation of GL n plus 1
look at GL n GL n plus 1 is where to
compare them which is just add a box on
the first row yes you can the GLM are so
good that's the symmetric group though I
mean you the number of boxes here so the
number of boxes in your young diagram is
yes but there is a way I mean you can
just increase the number so M you can
increase and there are inheritance
theorems to tell you that basically so
the spaces grow a lot but the
representation Theory basically stays
the same you see that the occurrences
will eventually stabilize yeah I mean if
you just increase the number of
variables and everything stabilized is
quite quickly but that's not what should
you also increase D here and then there
are stabilization theorems but those are
usually not the interesting lambdas that
you want to look at you want to have
some sequences where you're not actually
in this stabilizing range so we have
some example in the first disproof of
the first version of the conjecture
separating of course obstructions we
actually have when you find something
that is actually in some stable range
then you get XT infinitely good
obstructions so then you can get I mean
so everything has some finite complexity
or as you don't want to be in some
stable range right so we have to somehow
it's an interesting sequence
yes connection between these different
measures we'd like to do that you
presented the work and algebraic
branchings like yes so the war Lanka's
is less than that right yes is there
anything else you can say besides that
they separate yeah right
maybe you've been over the width of
another brush oh yeah so yeah you can
so the different algebraic whining
programs this classical algebra
complexity we studies a lot of different
types of utter black project programs
and and if you fix the width then this
is gives you algebraic formulas and if
you read through it also grow with the
other parameters this gives you skill
circuits yeah is that and you this and
you there's no way of getting me
completely so we don't know of a way of
getting VP
[Applause]